david solomon so goldman sachs
when when we were during covet i would
sit down with a lot of investment
bankers talk call them i would have
meetings with them right new york we go
have six seven eight meetings with them
and i would say
so tell me what your covet protocols are
right now with your company and i say
well you know we can only do zoom or we
can only do this and we can only do that
and we can't go to the office and we
can't travel and behind closed doors
they would say let me tell you the
goldman jets are off they're traveling
they're going and meeting with people
they're sitting down they're meeting
with the entrepreneur they're raising
the money for them
they're doing all that stuff
the reputation of david is they
capitalize during covet
i'm sure you have an opinion about david
solomon who he is and what he's done
what do you think about david solomon's
leadership
outstanding i mean comey's doing
extremely well he's a very engaged guy
it's a terrific firm
you know
i have nothing but good things to say
about goldman i sat down with a guy that
runs a 10 billion dollar company and we
had dinner uh last week or two weeks got
casa de angelo
and uh he said you know i just had
dinner with uh with solomon david
solomon
he said uh two months prior to that he
said he flew out on his jet not with a
team of five eight people he fought by
himself because they were trying to do a
round of 900 million whatever the number
was
he says he flew out by himself and we
sat down we talked and then he left he
had a two-hour meeting with me that's it
he just left i'm like he came himself
yeah he didn't send anybody else no he
came himself yes
you got to respect the leader like that
that's stupid remember remember what
jamie dimon said recently he said no
more zoom because he'd lost business of
course of course this is one time
solomon kind of took everyone's lunch
and you got to respect that i'm sure you
have an opinion also for jamie
i think jamie's uh almost a class by
himself i mean he's terrific i i have a
very high regard for that but i know him
well
um
and i think goldman i mean goldman is a
very accomplished firm very motivated
wants to do the business i had my own
experience you know i was one of the few
times i was ahead of goldman
in terms of thinking i ran goldman
research for many many years and uh i
kept on telling goldman you're making a
mistake by not being in the asset
management business
and for 10 years they told me lee you
don't get it we believe go money managed
to do money management a bit you know
brokers firms to do brokerage don't
compete with your customer because
goldman's traditional customers a
professional money manager i said open
up your eyes and look around the world
has changed you know merrill lynch asset
management uh webster which is division
of key key to peabody csfb everybody was
in the business
and they didn't want to do it then one
day uh solomon brothers who was an arts
trading rival in the 70s and 60s
announced that bob solomon jr was
leaving the research department to start
solomon brothers asset management and
steve friedman bob rubin called me up
they were there the co-heads of the firm
said you know you were right we were
wrong we made a mistake we should have
gone to asset management are you willing
to leave research and start an asset
management division for us
and i laughed i said sure uh it was a
mistake on my part because
goldman being the great firm it is
understood that assets under management
times fee equal revenue
and i was interested in the performance
of the assets not raising assets
and uh
after about a year of doing it i decided
i want to retire and become a full-time
money manager
uh but you know goldman when they go
into a business some they're not the
first but when they go into a business
they try to capture 100 market shares
they're very motivated g sam is a
monster yeah it is yeah and i started
it's a trillion dollar business now is
is it
sat down with a a small private equity
firm out of new york they came into my
house last week nice people good guys
and their team five people there goldman
sachs former goldman sachs 28 years
former goldman sachs 26 years former
goldman sachs 25 years former goldman
sachs 26 years
i see a lot after 25 years is there like
something that happens at 25 years at
goldman that people leave after 25 years
because
it's a great firm but i see a lot of 25
26 different now than it used to be
because people would spend their whole
careers there and then either only leave
to go into government or academia sure
uh you know
i don't know exactly what's changed but
i would say that uh
you know when you get up in the morning
you have one suit
you look in the closet you don't have to
spend a lot of time thinking about what
you're going to wear okay goldman you
know partners at age 50
are worth a lot of money
and you have more than one suit in the
closet and it's a very demanding
business very hard work i had a
voracious appetite for work so i didn't
leave over that i just wanted to do
something different i did not want to
run another business now
in research
self-praised things but we had a very
good team of sales research and trading
coordinating together when i took over
goldman research we were largely
unranked in these various surveys that
checked institutional investor ii
magazine
greenwich research which was founded by
charlie ellis financial world which
isn't in business anymore when i took
over the research department we were
unranked in those polls when i left the
research department we were number one
in every one of those surveys and there
was a category called portfolio strategy
which i competed in as a as a soloist
and uh for nine straight years i was
voted number one strategist so i was
ready for new mountain to climb and
that's when i went into asset management
but like i said i wanted to be a money
manager and uh
not an asset gatherer so i i selfishly
have to ask
how how did the federal reserve's
policies as they evolved
changed how you
how you
looked at managing money
well i would say the business has
changed not so much was the federal
reserve as business changed
because the machines now run the world
and i am highly critical of the sec
um you know
i wrote jay clayton a letter which he
never responded to he's now in private
practice
ironically he's chairman of the board of
apollo which i have a large position
when i wrote him a letter when he was
ahead of the sec he never responded i
pointed out to him when i came to
goldman sachs 50 odd years ago
goldman morgan stanley solomon traded
stocks for 25 50 cents a share and the
volcker rule didn't exist so the brokers
have the capacity and the willingness to
position and create liquidity they can't
anymore legally because of volcker and
economically because of the commission
structure there's no reward
secondly
50 years ago the specialist system
handled the new york stock exchange
handled 80 of the volume today 80
percent of the volume is off board in
dark pools and finally when i'm
particularly critical in i think 2007
they eliminated the uptick rule
which was enacted in 1938 in response to
the abuses of 29
and this gave rise to all the machines
to trade the way they trade and these
machines know nothing about value they
know everything about price and so the
market goes up too much when it goes up
it goes down too much when it goes down
and it's a destabilizing force
but
they don't seem to be focused on that
they seem to be focused more on the
trading costs
i don't know i just operate in the world
that i'm in i'm happy i'm not in the
money management game professionally
being paid a fee
i can take a long-term horizon
and
run the money for tax efficiency if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]